[Music]
hi everybody
I'm super excited to be here I'm Maria I
also work in the v8 team as a software
engineer and I'm going to talk about
parsing JavaScript so this focus could
not be about v8 the engine behind Google
Chrome and how we parse JavaScript so I
figured if I'm going to give a partial
talk I should probably tell you what
parsing is just to get everybody on the
same page and then why you should care
about it then I'm going to talk about
how v8 parses JavaScript and what you as
a web developer can do to help us device
better so what is parting so for those
who didn't see the previous talk the
parser gets the JavaScript source code
and construct data structures called ast
and scopes based on it I'll tell you in
a minute what those are
and then the byte code generator works
those data structures and generates byte
code the byte code is then executed by
the interpreter and the optimizing
compiler also can survive goods and
construct machines code base of it and
then the machine code is executed
directly so let's look at some simple
source code and what support it does
with it so the parser constructs an ast
and abstract syntax tree that describes
the structure of the source code for the
function there is a function literal and
then there is a variable declaration and
an assignment and every time we see a
variable name we create a variable proxy
object for it we don't yet know what
variable that is that just represents a
reference to a variable and the zero is
a literal then there is an if statement
it has a condition a send part and an
else part which is empty here
and the Stan part contains more code
there is another variable declaration
and an assignment and again we create
variable proxy objects to represent the
name of the variable and then there is a
return statement again with a variable
proxy so this is the ASP that the parser
generator based on the code in addition
to the ast the parser also generates
scopes where the functions where the
variables are the create so now for the
function there is one declaration scope
and for the if statement body there is
another scope and the declaration scope
contains the variable a and the if
statement body contains the variable B
and the scopes also contain the variable
reference is the variable proxies that
appear in the code which belongs to the
scope and then we do scope analysis this
means we connect the variable proxies to
the declared variables so in this phase
we figure out that all references to a
actually mean the variable declared in
the function and all reference is to be
in a different variable and to do this
it's not enough to just look at the
current scope where we in for example
with the return statement there is
written a but a is not declared in that
scope instead what we need to do is that
we work up the scope chain to find where
the variable is declared and now we find
it in the parent scope in the
declaration scope okay so this is quite
a lot of detail on one slide and in
reality it's even more interconnected I
just couldn't draw all the arrows on the
slides this was really exhausting to
make maybe it's also super exhausting to
look at but just look at this for a
second so why should you care about
parsing here's the diagram of where real
world web page is centered on in v8
so parting is the orange blob on the
left and turns out the web page is spent
around 2015 to 20% of their v8 I'm
importing so parsing is definitely on
the critical path for
a startup according to Google's
production web app study a typical
single page web app loads around 0.4
megabytes of JavaScript and spent around
370 milliseconds parsing it on mobile so
that's quite a lot of time if you think
about it so this means that our parsing
speed is roughly 1 megabyte per second
on mobile so how does v8 parse
JavaScript I'm going to talk about our
two parsing modes eager and lazy and
then a bit about why parsing is hard and
why benchmarking it is hard so we
actually don't have one quarter we have
two parters they are called parser and
pre parser for historical reasons parser
is the full eager one it's used for
parsing functions we want to compile
right now it builds the AST it builds
the Scopes that I showed before and it
finds all syntax errors in the code pre
parser on the other hand is the fast
lazy one it's just for you used by
skipping functions we don't want to
compile at least not right now
so it basically just points where the
function ends so that we can carry on it
doesn't build an AST it builds scopes
but it doesn't put variable references
or variable declarations in the Scopes
it's approximately twice as fast as
parser and it only finds a restricted
set of errors so it doesn't actually
comply with the x max respect but we are
somehow getting away with it so here's
an example of how we use these two
parses to parse your JavaScript code so
all top level code is eager we use the
actual parser to parse it when we see an
iffy and immediately invoked function
expression or something we recognize as
an EC we eager for that so in this
example there is a parent before the
functions we figure out the pieces
probably because you want to call the
function right after so which would
equal force that and in this case again
is correct and there actually is a call
to this function so this is eager part
other top-level functions which are not
if these are lazy parts so we use the
pre parser for parsing that function
body and later on at some point in time
you might want to call this function so
at that point when you call the function
the function is then eager forest and
compiled and executed there are some
other heuristics if there is an
exclamation mark before the function
that turns the function eager and if
that is then followed by comma and
another function then this is also eager
and then you can have another command
more functions these are all eager here
are some trickier lazy versus eager
cases so the problem is that we need to
make the decision on which parser to use
before we see the function body or
anything that follows the function body
so basically we need to see it when we
see the function token so in the first
example we assign a function to a
variable and this function is lazy
there is no parent before it this is
fine we just use the pre part here and
lazy part this function the second
example looks just like the first one
except we call this function and assign
the return value of that call to f2 but
we cannot know it when we need to make a
decision on whether to parse or pre part
or whether to eager voice related by
this function so we end up making the
exact same definite decision in both
cases so in the second line we also lazy
parse this and when this line is
executed we need to eat your parses
right after and compile it but this is
it was kind of the wrong decision but we
just couldn't know based on like the
code that we have seen so far so these
lazy versus eager rules are not
specified in the spec each engine is
free to implement them as they see fit
or they don't need to implement lazy
parting at all if they don't like to so
v8 just tries to guess based on the
syntax which functions are probably
called and then equal parts those
functions and lazy parts rest so why is
this relevant for you so turns out we
need lazy parsing
because
web pages ship a lot of code they don't
execute at least not on not on startup
so we want to use as little work for
doing what you have needlework for for
processing that code that is not needed
it's also important that we pick the
right one to use if we either parse
something that is not needed we're just
wasting time it's unnecessary on the
other hand if we lazy parse something
that is needed then we pay the cost of
pre part and right after the cost of
parse and the pre parts cost is half the
first cost and then the actual parts
cost so that's like one and a half times
the parts cost that we need to pay of
course the problem is knowing what code
is executing on startup you can also
force eager partings by wrapping
functions that are critical for start-up
in parents so that will force the eager
parsing and eager compilation of those
functions there is library code
optimizer j/s that does this so it has
some rules on like what function should
should have parents around them and then
that results in speed ups with most of
the browser's but really we should just
parse and compile the right functions
like not depending on whether parents
are in funny places in your code
we should also minimize the cost for
cases where we get the guest wrong so
this is an area that we are actively
working on in the b18 lazy parsing inner
functions is more complicated and lazy
parsing top level code and to understand
why we need to look at context
allocation so here is some example code
there is a function order which is an e
theme there is a parent before the
function and a call right after so we
eager parse that so that function has a
variable local variable called a and
then it has an inner function that
returns this local variable and then
this function outer returns a reference
to the inner function so now we call
this function and assign the return
value to F so now F will be a reference
to inner and then we call F and we print
out the return value so
this will print out 20 as you might
expect but where is the 20 coming from
so normally when you call a function its
local variables are put on the stack but
here when we are calling F we are not
inside a call to order so it definitely
kind of be on the stack so where is it
the fun the answer is it's in the
function context so a function context
is an object which the inner function
also refers to and keeps it alive so now
we have a reference the inner function
because F is a reference to it so that's
how the function context is then kept
alive and when F accesses when inner
accesses the variable a it reads it from
the function context so if you want to
lazy part inner function if you want to
lazy part inner in this case we need to
know which variables they refer to so
that we can put those variables in the
function context and not put other
variables there we don't want to put all
variables to the function context
because accessing them from there it
just wastes lower than accessing them
from the stack
so normally lazy parsing doesn't care
about variable names but now we need to
so we need something like lazy parsing
with names and the speed for doing that
is somewhere between parser and
precursor so this means that lazy
parting inner functions will always be
heavier than lazy parsing top level
functions just because of these
semantics modern JavaScript is heavily
nested maybe 15 years ago you might have
had like lot of top-level functions you
don't have that anymore
everything is wrapped in EP functions
everything's a module now so this is the
price you have to pay for nesting
functions like that in some situations
v8 also has to report code that it has
already lazy parsed so in this example
there is delay the outer function there
is no parent before the function so we
lazy parse it and we of course lazy
parts everything inside the function -
and then when we call this lazy other
functions we need to do something for
inner
how it currently works is that we need
to pre park or lazy parts in ER again
even though we have lazy parts it's
already once and it gets even worse if
you nest more so now in the first run
when we go through the code we're lazy
for lazy order and lazy parts everything
inside it so be lazy parts in ER and
lazy parts in o2 at some point you call
lazy order so at that point we eager for
lazy order because that's the code you
want to execute and then we lazy parts
inner and inner - then again if you call
inert we eager for inner because that's
the goal you want to call now and then
we need to lazy bars in o2 for the third
time so obviously this is quite bad this
is not how it should work and this is
something that I am personally working
on instead of lazy parsing we should
just keep those functions if we have
already lazy watch the ones so why is
parking hard the JavaScript grammar is
not ambiguous as such but it contains
some constructs where we don't know
upfront what we are parsing one example
is arrow function parameter list and
comma expressions so they look just the
same if you just see opening parent ABC
you don't really know what that is maybe
it's a function parameter list or maybe
it's just a comma expression it's also
possible that it's a valid comma
expression but not a valid arrow
function parameter list if you see a one
- that's a valid comma expression but a1
2 is not a valid arrow function
parameter list but we don't really know
like whether this is an error or not
before we see whether there is an arrow
following following the expression we
just cannot know well for example when
we see the one the other way around is
also possible so a dot B is perfectly
okay arrow function parameter list
it's just error function with the rest
param but a dot B is not on okay commas
expression and this is also something we
just cannot know when we are parsing we
don't know whether the user intends to
use it as a error function parameter
list so how the v8 parser solve this is
that it never rewinds
instead when it's parting an unknown
construct its parsing a very permissive
grammar that allows both kind of
constructs and then it records whether
it has seen something that makes it the
valid error invalid error function
parameter list or an invalid comma
expression and then when we see the
closing parent we can check if there an
arrow and if there is an arrow we check
what's the thing that we just parsed a
valid error function parameter list so
we just check the information we
recorded when parsing that but we don't
jump back and report it or anything like
that so parser also has very high future
complexity and new language features are
added to it all the time so here is a
typical parser bug that I found some
time ago the bug is eager parsing fails
with stack code okay but like what is
this even so it's there is a variable G
and we assign to G an arrow function the
error function has three parameters
there is the destructuring X and then
there is G and the parameter G has a
default value and the default value is
again an arrow function with an empty
parameter list and a body and the body
is eval X so now if I force eager
parsing if I disable lazy parsing then
this fails so we call the function G
without providing a value for G so the
default value kicks in and then this
evil is just confusing
I have no idea what you're talking about
what is this X even though it should
resolve to the parameter X so the
beach's involved in this bug are lazy
versus eager a destructuring
there is the destructuring X turns out
this is not relevant so this bug is also
reproducible without the destructuring
there are default parameters there are
arrow functions and now an arrow
function is used as a default parameter
to another error function and then there
is evil and it's important that the evil
is in the body of an
a function which is a default parameter
so this is just to give you an idea of
the sort of complexity that we are
dealing with in our everyday work
benchmarking parsing is also non-trivial
here I have the mock benchmarks
benchmark one is not even a parsing
benchmark if some random benchmark it
has one big function with lots of code
and the function looks just like a lazy
function there is no parent before it
it's not an EP and then the actual
benchmark start the timer calls these
functions and measures how long it took
but now if we implement lazy parsing the
way I described we need to parse the
function when the timer is running and
this is really bad for the benchmark for
the benchmark it would be MIT way better
to just do as much work upfront as we
can I like parse and compile everything
when the timer is not running yet
so if even though we need lazy parsing
for the web it really makes a benchmark
score here worse it's a difficult
trade-off and there is another benchmark
benchmark too that tries to be a parting
benchmark so what they typically do is
we start the timer the Evo a lot of code
and then we measure how long it took so
okay this is fair like this definitely
exercises parsing when the time is
running but this is totally not how you
browse your lost JavaScript when you
load JavaScript from a file from a
resource the holy different code path
kicks in as in here and for example
there are some improvements we do for
the standard code path for the normal
code path for example we download and
parse scripts in parallel and these kind
of improvements don't benefit this kind
of benchmark at all because evil is just
not using the same code path so what can
you do to help us part better so none of
the stuff I talked about can be sort of
black and white like do this or like
absolutely don't do that I can only tell
you like how things look from the parser
point of view and
then you can sort of figure out what's
the good trade off for you in your use
case so a lot of the stuff you can find
in a blog post called JavaScript started
performance the first thing is she
placed JavaScript please so that we
don't need to parse so much you can also
use the code coverage functionality in
dev tools to see what parts of your code
are not needed or not needed on startup
so maybe it's possible to lazy load some
of that code you can also measure the
parse cost of your code and the
dependencies with chrome tracing and the
v8 runtime stats in it so here you can
see the concrete number of milliseconds
that VA spends bars in your code v8 also
has this feature called code caching
where we cache the byte code of
frequently used scripts so whenever you
load the same script frequently v8
detects fat and put byte code of that
script into a cache and the next time
you load the script we don't need to
part it we don't need to compile it we
just read the byte code directly from
the cache so this affects bundling if
you bundle a lot of your JavaScript
libraries into one file and then you
want to update one part of it you lose
the code cut for the full bundle we
won't be able to figure out that you
have just updated one part of the bundle
so this is just something to be aware of
when bundling and updating your code I
already mentioned streaming that means
we start parsing a script while it's
downloading before it has finished
downloading the full script so it makes
sense to use this for big scripts and to
use them optimally you should load them
as early as possible and async so that
the streamer kicks in and you can also
make sure that the streamer is released
streaming your script with chrome
tracing here you will see the streamer
thread in the thread there will be an
event partial background and in the
event you can see the name of the script
that got streamed
there is very little we can do for
evolve so there won't be streaming for
that there won't be cold cash for that
it makes sense to avoid it about
availing big chunks of code if you can
in some situations it makes sense to use
the parents had to force eager parsing
and eager compilation of the critical
path in your code this makes sense for
example if you need to support older
chrome versions if you need performance
across browser or if you need
performance right now and can't wait for
us to fix our code but we're working on
sort of making these hacks less and less
relevant in the future so the recycle
bonus content so here is bonus content
this is code from the v8 partner it's a
hundred and recursive descent parser
written in C++ it's fifteen thousand
lines of code another seven thousand for
the in perhaps a Sdn scopes so here we
are inside Berkeley statement so the
return type of that statement and the
first thing we expect to see is token if
this is already checked a Bob before
calling this function and then we expect
to see a left parent if there is no less
parent that this is a syntax error and
we bail out of this function so then we
recurse we call a function called part
expression for parting to condition this
is why the parser is called recursive
descent parser and then we expect the
right parent after it there we record
again for parsing 10-part now if of
course possible that the pen part
contains another if statement so we will
end up in this function in a recursive
manner then we check if they're a token
l if we record against for parting the
else part
if there is no else we do
I think and then in the end we construct
the ASD node for the if statement so
this is roughly how it looks like it's
handwritten so it's not order generated
by any rule file or anything like that
so here are some things you might want
to remember from shop if you have
further questions or comments or want to
talk about parsing in general just
please get in touch
thanks for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]